بعد قرابه الشهر على دراما العائله
الملكيه وخلافاتها تتجه الانظار نحو معضله
جديده معضله دعوه الامير هاري الى حفل
تنصيب والده اسئله كثيره تراود المؤسسه
الملكيه هل تتم دعوته هل يتم اعطائه فرصه
جديده في الاجتماعات العائليه والسؤال
الاهم من سيكون مسؤولا عن ابلاغه بعدم
حضور الحفل
اجوبه تسارع المؤسسه الملكيه الى ايجاد
صيغه لحسمها قبل ثلاثه اشهر على حفل تتويج
الملك تشارلز وهو ما يبدو انه اثار عده
سيناريوهات يتم بحثها حاليا اولا مصالحه
محتمله بين الامير هاري وعائلته كالخيال
الافضل للمضيق قدما والاسرع وقتا لتجنب
المزيد من الاحراج واشارت مصادر مطلعه من
القصر الى ان اجتماعا في طور التحضير بين
هاري والملك وولي عهده
الامر
يريد المصالح
كما تتم مناقشه خطه بديله في حال فشل
المصالحه تكمن في عدم دعوى هاري لحضور حفل
تنصيب وتدرس المؤسسه في هذا الصدد نقل
مسؤوليتي ابلاغ هاري بعدم دعوته من يد
الملك تشارلز الى يد رئيس الوزراء ريشي
سوناك الذي يحق له بهذه الحاله اتخذه موقف
منهاري باعتبار انه لا يملك لقبا ملكيا
وان حفله تنصيب هو مناسبه تخص الدوله
تحقيق المصالحه بين هاري وعائلته يكمل في
استعداد الطرفين لوضع خلافته ما جانبا
وربما الاهم على قدره هذه لتخلي عن هجومه
ضد عائلته التي عاده ما تتبع شعار لا تشرح
لا تتدمر ولكن هل ينجح هاري في دفع عائلته
الى التخلي عن شعارها والتصعيد ضد الضغط
العربي العربيه